very casual very comfortable guys I'm
introducing a new segment here on its
grace it's called wine time Cheers
it's felt different okay like why they
didn't plane I think that every now and
then it's great to sit down with a
friend or stand up strangely with a
friend do a yoga pose with a friend have
a glass of wine and just let it all out
complain about I went on my Facebook
page and I asked you guys for good rant
topics and we got a ton can't live
I can't wait the first one is cold
weather being cold coldness snow winter
ice slipping on ice all of it is awful
huh also what they do in New York is
know if we can blast you with heat right
yeah you leave like that's gonna
compensate what your body's gonna be
like oh okay I can even out know now
it's like a one last gentle kiss slap
yeah and you're way out the door like oh
now I live in Los Angeles and it's made
me a soft sensitive human being that
hates cold instantly instantly instant
not even like a during Christmas or
anything no but you're from Florida I am
from Florida I've never felt cold I just
didn't get excited about
I felt like lifelessness and soul is not
like a temperature shift slow walkers oh
yeah okay I think maybe you can relate
to me on this I have long legs so my
stride is a little I think bigger than
the normal also having lived in New York
and having to get places quickly I have
a pace now to my normal walk that is
pretty quick you are wondering lie to me
and you are slow I will be cursing you
in my head with words that I didn't even
know I knew Thanks I'm like that in the
grocery store or the worst place is for
me recently a target I'd like developed
a hatred of target uh uh and so when
people are walking slowly it pisses me
off because I just want to get in and
get out get on okay
that was on the elevator going down to
the parking garage in my apartment out
here and this person like she gets in
and she's like no like I think we're
gonna do is probably like I'd love
working with her and she has this little
bag and just good
slams into me I thought she didn't
notice until the very end of the
elevator ride she to Gilligan
very end of the elevator ride she turns
to me and she's like sorry and then
walks off I should know that I'm right
here like I'm very talky in my head I've
already lit a match and burned her
person oh I hate in elevators if someone
comes at the elevator and then they
stand really close to you but there's a
whole other area of elevator that is for
standing if you were another person
that's a serial killer [ __ ] who
don't replace the empty toilet paper
roll with a new one I feel like what
you've been this person I try not to be
but um here's the thing so we keep our
toilet paper like over the toilet right
so like it's very easy just to be like
oh I'm out here's a roll
I'll just kind of put it off to the side
it's still there yeah accessible I think
I hate people that don't make their
toilet paper accessible in a bathroom
because I've been to house parties where
it's like oh the toilet paper pit you're
like what in here is disposable like use
this face cloth is about to bake I want
every household have a bidet have you
used one no other countries they don't
have a toilet paper and they think it's
like ridiculous that we take wads of
paper and use that to clean ourselves
which when you think about is totally
true it's a very strange way I'm toilet
paper uh I mean not to like throw
countries under the bus working with
people who constantly talk down to you
because you are a millennial and
therefore you are deemed quote unquote
useless in the workplace that's heavy
yeah somebody was ranting they wrote
that got a situation we I think kind of
luck out on this because we have jobs
based on the fact yeah we're kind of
millennial officially with what we do
because it's all digitally based and you
got these old people have no idea what
they're talking about have no idea they
think because they have a cell phone
that they have any concept of like what
snapchat is they have no idea what
snapchat is I don't know what snapchat
is but I know it more than Doris and
accounting does exactly forkin Doris
with the glasses you know fooling
anybody think she's are in pencil skirts
that's like the whole bone marker yeah
that's a sharpie for sure or you can
take your anger and you can fall it up
and just hold it within you forever ever
yeah Elliot thank you for being here on
the first edition of wine time Asians
like professionals make sure you go over
to Elliot's channel we showed a video
over there and it was really really fun
well it will be once we shoot it yeah
I'm gonna roll with it yeah yeah no it
was good remember all the time also are
you on snapchat yeah I am on snapchat my
username is Elliot sucks if that gives
you I think my goal is make a worse
snapchat possible I'm just wasting
people's time yeah it's very rude yeah
well I think that's snapchat in general
it should strip everyone wasting
everyone else's time so go follow him on
snapchat yeah see you guys later I don't
know
if my [ __ ] needs because I'm using
your tongue whatever all of it and if
you don't have any I'm using whatever
you got in there